Beyond the hypes;
let's talk about how machine learning actually solve real problems
but before then we really need to understand the term machine learning
and how it really works
when you hear machine learning
often time what we're talking about is
how can you program application without you explicitly telling
or coding every aspect of the instruction
when we look at how we used to code
often times you would have to combine
lots of conditional statements to get things done
these things can get messy very easily
because when you need to give condition in certain instances
at the end of the day before you know
you've written hundred lines of code and still yet
when consumers or users gets to use the application
you find out that you haven't even occupied or done some scenarios
and before you know your code breaks
this is where machine learning shines
when you really want to entrust the condition of your programming
or of your application to a particular model
to help you solve the problem whenever it arises
if you're still wondering what all this is all about
yes it's fine
it's possible that you can code an application just normally
but think about it
do you want to build something that gets more intelligent
based on the data available
there are a lot of examples
that can help us solve some of these things
so to put this straight
Machine Learning is the science of programming application
through data
what does this mean again
well just think of it as you wanna build an application
but you're not sure how things are gonna pan out
the variables are so complex
you're not really sure some of the condition
then machine learning can help you